welcome to this video playing hmm hey
Decker I don't know people actually
advise me how to pronounce it and okay
let's concentrate on the game I had this
line against him before and it didn't
really turn out to be so so great maybe
maybe it's better this time we had
exactly the same thing
Yossi going keep going to play nazi for
whom ok it's tricky if you don't play
one year for regularly what to do here
hmm Jim he takes Knight c4 that's not
how do I protect me to even cannot I
cannot play would be one or something
that's it simply too too too meek should
be three maybe yeah that's probably not
great at all now the dragon is a tricky
open if you really don't don't play if
are regularly that some demand some
specific knowledge without which I are
rather than I simply don't have yeah
maybe I should play the the the rouser
type of attack would have three and
blown castles at least I know the plan
made the king okay sure simply simply
not great all this
okay this fields okay from to me now at
least at least I'm not worth worth worse
worse I'm not drunk and just screw it up
the pronunciation like g4 here maybe
this an idea I don't really know what
his ideas was to UM go for this
structure because this fields like I
should be okay i mean the FR the
certainty good for me i have got Bishop
e3 threatened and i have threatened
bishop f6 here which is really a big
problem so we cannot just play 6 i'll
take a 95 and that's it why it is almost
strategically winning after that way at
least very good for white yeah this is
some probably what you should do but if
i go Queenie to okay i don't want to
take even more time checking here and
threatening 95 what is he doing if he
takes on f2 Queen takes bishop t4 I've
got Bishop e3 that's not a problem and
g4 is just hanging ND 7s hanging hmm
what does smooth now
yeah not it does not like to play that
but probably did it needed to be done
you know I still eat seven hangs right f
successor is not not good well I'd say
maybe you must do that but it's nothing
you like to do it's hanging on a on g4
yeah the good the question is should i
take it really i mean this is good but
yeah come on it's just in structure and
now queen f 3 f 6 is some an additional
weakness i wonder if i should play Queen
III here yeah keep it simple just keep
it simple there's a7 hanging so I have
fun time to to alter the center here of
three King I here i can play rook e8 and
f5
wow that's not not so convincing William
he might play rook e8 and f5 and then
rookie to was something like that yeah
yeah he can take a six you know if it
takes rook takes it still should should
be a little something
yeah i think this still should be good I
mean I have got I got the simple plan to
get the King to deform and it's not so
easy to prevent that I have the open a
file and these points are simply weaker
than mine don't he's giving away the
spawn are maybe for the default
counterplay interesting yeah okay I need
to take any way takes d4 takes c3 yeah
okay I don't have any big choice now
maybe I should have rewarded I mean this
is a draw time morning I will continue
but it is a draw of course this has been
lost so often the time that you can you
can try
I mean this is somewhat better than and
you often get but so not not enough to
do to do something substantial Jack but
I'm making progress IAM you defended
this a bit sloppy limb yeah this already
is very good check probably probably
winning
yeah I think this is winning I don't see
a movie I'm threatening f7 here this is
not some also winning rookie form I'm
driving the King away or just f7 I mean
is the zooks bug actually black for fits
on time no yeah you still need to defend
it I mean it it was a relatively good
version of this end game because I got
got h 4g phone but he can defend much
better of more ch.5 was this one one
thing that you should do to get pawns
exchanged so after g4 I can take this is
the easiest to play this I mean it's
still probably a draw but it around here
i'm i'm thinking i think it's it's
tricky it's tricky already i I don't
know if he wants to allow age six and if
you take I got the the free f porn it's
a it's not so so easy anymore yeah champ
this d5 was a good defense really very
good defense they are very strong t5
otherwise he will suffer really suffer
yeah very tricky the whole end game oh
here the computer d5 very strong very
strong look at this that's that's very
nice now alright thanks for watching